Space Balls lovingly sent up the George
Lucas Saga but also pointed out just how
silly it all was with Rick Moranis as
the unsure Darth Bader esque Dark Helmet
Bill Pullman as the on the- noos ha solo
parody Lone Star and John Candy as the
Chewbacca like barf Brooks himself even
shows up for an extended Cameo as yogurt
an old and wise Yoda ripoff who's
literally just there to sell merch
naturally considering the franchise it's
spoofing Space Balls also promises a
sequel in Space Balls 2 the search for
more money sadly this will probably
never happen since many members of the
original cast have passed away since the
first film's 1987 release most
importantly of all however Moranis has
almost entirely retired from acting and
as the 94-year-old Brooks once told
Parade Magazine without Rick I wouldn't
do it